right now I think education is one of
the least eight of different fields that
exists and it's it's sort of amazing we
spent all this time all this after all
this money on this extremely important
thing but then when you pick a random
student the student doesn't really have
a great picture of what they need to do
it improving I'm Arjun Singh I'm 29 and
I'm the CEO and co-founder of great Co
we help instructors ready to see this
work the idea is a rather than grading
with a red pen on paper we're gonna
grate on computer something save a lot
of time and also help them understand
what their students are doing much more
effectively and so they can actually
take a look at what the most common
mistakes are that fishin's are making
I'm just kinda stuff that they have and
alter how they teach now that we've had
so much work graded on great scope we
can actually help them grade even faster
by automating it today for
multiple-choice questions for short math
questions or short text questions that
have a couple of words or maybe one
formula in it we can actually help the
instructors do this automatically and so
there's two big benefits out one is that
I saved from a ton of time but the other
is that it's extremely consistent
there's no worry about one student with
the same answer to giving you different
score from another to do so this is a
way for instructing to focus on one
thing at a time they're grading it that
one examiner that won't harm consignment
they're going through making sure it's
done consistently correctly and then
after the fact they get to go through
the review what actual would happen in a
way that they could not do on paper
[Music]
in five years we want to be the
foundation for dated in education and
what I mean by that is a system where
everybody knows the best next thing to
do the school knows how to optimize the
programs the instructor knows how to how
to make their instructions better the
student knows how to make your own
learning experience better the student
can take anything any any given field
chemistry math biology whatever it is it
trying to learn you have an infinite
supply of practice questions and any
time the answer actually get immediate
feedback we'd say okay this is where you
went right that's where you went wrong
you want to focus on this little piece
here we're gonna give the next best
question we're gonna put you the next I
like your video the the perfect check
this textbook chapter or whatever is but
it's data judgments based on where the
student is it's based on what we know
about the student and integrates that
all together the best piece of advice
that I've gotten is talk to our users
and our customers one thing that we've
really been focused on is building in
the best possible user experience we
possibly could and we're extremely user
driven and now we're focused on you know
the the teachers our end users and now
we're focused on how about how to make
the universities we're actually going to
making the sale to now that'll make them
[Music]
you